[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's in the box I am The Green Hornet
I am Kato that means he's got a weapon
on him Kato whips out his weapon man
Green Hornet says stop [ __ ] I think
that's how that show used to go they
stab into the Box gingerly you're doing
it sorry for a minute [ __ ] fabergé
move in like it could be lifted
Oh like there's a puppy in it yes it
might surprise this one day you're like
I'm we pull out dead for all [ __ ] son
look at this good times are about to be
had kids cuz we're going back to the
Hundred Acre Woods of Prince of Thieves
I love this movie really yeah I actually
like this movie that's movie took [ __ ]
back of the day this was the line of
figures where nobody looked like anybody
in the movie look at every picture on
the box yeah let's start with Costner
himself chef calls us outlaws but I say
we are free there's Kevin Costner
that ain't Kevin Costner nah the great
Alan Rickman we all know what he looks
like join us or die there he is
Hans Gruber from die hard does that
looks like Captain Hook of course young
Jack Nicholson mr. robot himself will
scarlet as played by the great Christian
Slater series all river and any man who
wishes to cross
that looks like a guy that Christian
Slater got served by a Burger King or
something like that that doesn't look
like Christian Slater Morgan Freeman is
right there that is not Morgan Freeman
Friar Tuck Michael McShane he was the
the guy on Seinfeld he was also an
office space he's the one that
hypnotized is the dude and then he lies
and [ __ ] three two one
[Music]
great character actor did voices the
clerks coaching he's about the closest
you come number one he's too short
look at me looks like a Jawa it's very
much but number two like heavy dude with
a beard is an easy figure too I mean I
look like this guy I look as much like
Friar Tuck as Friar Tuck looks like
Friar Tuck this has to be one of the
worst action figure lines in history
maybe even worse than the Dick Tracy
line oh look they have though they have
a battle wagon yeah we don't have that
they have a Sherwood Forest playset no
not that either
we got the Bolla bomber look at this
this is the gold in this box - OH back
in the day man whenever you bought a
counter product there would be a little
toy booklet inside this is the true gold
in the box this week dude open it up
that's Batman the first Batman movie
they called The Dark Knight collection
look they had the Batmobile - batwing
and then you keep turning the pages dude
it's like oh my god I want this - look
it's Wayne Manor and the Batcave look at
how much fun we're having we haven't
even touched the [ __ ] toys sometimes
a catalog is all you need it's the
promise of [ __ ] remember the Sears wish
book from where kids like around
Christmas time and had pictures of all
the toys that were coming out for the
rest of the year we would play with that
as a toy because our parents would never
be able to afford anything in the Sears
Bush book this was a miniature version
of that dude now they start getting into
this look at this [ __ ] all they did was
take the Endor place s and repaint it
they thought a kid bunch of kids
wouldn't notice 10 years later but you
know what I noticed
and that's why did - [ __ ] I was like I
bought it once already when it said it
you walk on it you pieces of [ __ ] flip
this page oh oh the whole world Swamp
Thing Oh too bad
baseball figures sports that's for dicks
Beetlejuice figures [ __ ] voluntad
figures there's a George Carlin figure
man Rufus you could literally play Dogma
now there's an Alan Rickman figure
here's George Carlin figure there you're
halfway there and now we get to the
roster dude like look at this Peter
Venkman ray Stantz Egon Spengler is
based on the cartoon
next page is gonna have the ambulance ha
ha call the dude there's ecto-1 why
didn't they offer that to adults I would
have bought that look at this I would
throw that [ __ ] right onto your brow
this was amazing and where how much
would you pay for this when we tell you
right now I beg [ __ ] 20 bucks that
was worth 20 bucks for the memories
easily 20 bucks in order to get a kids
you don't have to buy it you just have
to buy this crappy thing which [ __ ] I
think you put together we can do this
yeah this [ __ ] was one more time now
ready go ahead oh this was the second
highest grossing movie of 1991 can you
Jason news named the number one movie of
1991
can you name it give me 3 mins okay the
first tenth it was not Robin Hood Prince
of Thieves
[Music]
second hint it's the second movie in a
franchise plus the first in many hearts
here's your third hint it's not
Terminator 3 its Terminator 2 good
Terminator 2 is the number one hit of
1991
this [ __ ] dude this will Scarlett
says [ __ ] remember he goes [ __ ] me
cleared it
it's a pg-13 movie is the first time I
think somebody said [ __ ] and they got
away with it
sorry to keep you hanging about Alan
Rickman's performance one of the
greatest Grillin performances of all tap
before you fail I will personally remove
your lying tongue he somehow was able to
top or add to Hans Gruber machine oh
that's what everyone loves about this
movie and call off Christmas cats on
Christmas like he was [ __ ] phenomenal
[Music]
my spoon cousin they don't have that guy
that figure man likewise spoon cousin
cousin this doll of you twit hot they're
two different Robin Hood's one is
crossbow Robin Hood and longbow Ross's
longbow yeah remember Kevin Costner's
amazing accent in the movie and know how
it feels to be so far from your home and
family it was like hi maid Mary Ann Oh
like he didn't even try for the bridge
at all he was just like why bother I'm
Costner they don't give a [ __ ] I thought
you'd say that
do you remember the theme song of this
movie
[Music]
was there come on sir remembers his
wife's name to Jordan good okay no it
it's on the tip of my doing everything I
do I do it for you my theme song to you
yes you didn't you were in clothes what
were you saying I was thinking now take
that whip that do the nae nae nae no one
current songs everything they don't take
long to pull these out you can really
put the arrow through the bow here this
is the hole very nice let's see okay
look at this dude they'd even try
nothing about this looks remotely you
can actually play a Ford Fairlane with
these figures here you can watch a three
hour director's cut of this movie
directed by Kevin Reynolds leave uh I
imagine you betcha has more Alan Rickman
it to that's worth watching right there
I may go for it you know what I'm saying
it opens at with him they escaped saved
my life question I will stay with you
once and I have saved yours so they get
on the boat they're finally kisses the
dirt and goes I'm home I'm home I'm back
go home and he goes come on Robin and he
goes I don't need your service anymore
tonight Vicki to free yourself to go Val
return with the boat and he goes but I
have a lifelong debt to you and he's
like no and then he tries to swing at
him or hurt him or something and he goes
by
I had to try because I had to try and
then he [ __ ] them and anyway they go
and he's praying up here and he's here
and then the little boy comes over and
he's like running the dogs are chasing a
little boy and then sheriff's like oh no
no it's him
no it's uh what's his name William
Scarlett Oh we'll see I can't even tell
because you don't look like a man look
which one's Christian Slater clearly not
cuspid he's like he's still a deer from
our line I'm hungry and then he gets in
a fight this is my land in my tree
therefore whatever's in it also belongs
to me he's like this is more land than I
can't go to that movie is actually a
really good movie a lot of people maybe
haven't checked it out in the wall but
in terms of the Robin Hood movies of the
last 50 years yes hello I'm hood like
it's more enjoyable than the [ __ ] one
with grouchy Mick throw my phone what's
his name gladiator Russell Crowe his
Robin Hood tower and shitty thanks for
the warning how much would you pay for
all this crap back in the day I would
have paid Jack or [ __ ] yeah and I liked
the movie I saw the movie opening day
can I tell you something yes in a world
of embarrassing admissions yes I want to
see this movie by myself no you didn't I
did man
nobody else would know I was a jerk at
all why can't I just enjoy the song
without [ __ ] jerking off did you get
sad and then you can always cry when I
try so it's only when you're in the room
I gotta be honest with you I saw this
flick by myself yeah I remember going to
the movie theater box office and going
like one please for Robin Hood crispy on
the dislike one and I was like yep and
one like nobody will go with me I asked
wall to go he was like that looks stupid
he wouldn't go I want to go to first
show most people like pay for you this
is 1991 before I'm a clerk so I had no
money you were like the human [ __ ]
like can I have I was like a living ATM
from anywhere always like move so just
need a little money I couldn't have a
job I was in [ __ ] high school I know
him what was the 16 year old boy asking
a 21 year old man for things that's true
I used to have me do those things
let's die no in any event
what would you pay for this craft back
in the 1991 $47.99
man $4.99 sure they had many points of
articulation and yeah they didn't look
like the movie at all but $4.99 was the
nice price you know how much you pay
from right now I would say $8.99 no
actually it goes for more good all right
a longbow Robin Hood he's gone for 1035
whoa 10 bucks
that's right now Friar Tuck with battle
stash how much would you pay for that
figure P like booze to remember here's a
drunk priest well let's see what he
looks like underneath oh my god he looks
like he looks like the [ __ ] rank
Corps oh my god
dude you're right his body is a Kenner
gomorian Guard dude yeah they're so
[ __ ] lazy they couldn't even they put
a new head on him yes but it's
definitely a good morning over just hide
it would have with a Jawa cape yeah I
would say he's worth right now $14.99 no
$6.99 ok and it actually says he's just
a repainted gomorian guard toy if we
read the cards we would know the
immigrants more exciting fearing out on
our own
you were you really just a flesh man and
[ __ ] murder shoes yeah come to life
Kenner when I was a kid made this toy
set for Star Wars called the droid
factory it was full of a bunch of parts
and you could build your own [ __ ]
droids Ivan [ __ ] that's literally what
they did with the Robin hotline there
was like let's just put them together
repaint him and call Robin Hood like
Kenner was like oh my god we already got
a bolo on our figure with arm straps
oh yeah mazing we paint this guy brown
instead of green pop a head on them
looks nothing like Kevin Costner we got
a line of toys all right Azim with a
scimitar for cemeteries some people are
pronounced the suit yeah one of the only
official Morgan Freeman figures in the
marketplace it's a Shazam body with
green arrow arms
can you imagine that's crazy man sheriff
Nottingham the head is taken from
Kenner's Robocop ultra police chainsaw
figure so this this ain't even the
[ __ ] Sheriff of Nottingham like this
is crazy now we got to talk about this
the bola bomber
almost the ball of honor right there
original price $9.99 it does [ __ ] it
launches things what would you pay for
that now I would save $20 $19.99 okay
about 15 to 20 bucks for it unlike the
entire rest of the line this appears to
have been an original design so clearly
this wasn't used in the end or line but
you know that tree house Wow totally boy
that's what they should have done is put
a walks into this line see if anybody
noticed you know what I'm saying just
like yeah yeah remember that he walks
[Music]
[Applause]
so there it is man the entire craptastic
line of Robin Hood Prince of Thieves
boy what lazy creds like the [ __ ] I
don't know tusk of toys just try a
little harder I want to open up a box of
just all these older toy Hamlet's
different ones different years to
different toys and different versions
that's a good idea man then I'd open a
box with that you want to see his open
up a whole bunch of other stuff man
let us know right to the screen junkies
and tell them the things that you would
like to see yourself on over Twitter
over Facebook at this address beneath us
right here that's covering my hand so I
could do this you can see me jerking off
right now that dress is covered take the
dress away oh look at that you miss the
whole thing
come back next time man and we'll look
at more stuff inside of the box until
then I've been Kevin Smith J Samuel I
know what was in the box was just teabag
time write that look at you you got oral
skills son
[Music]